[Music]
access
yes
the proof
[Applause]
hello good media ghm we're listening to morgan 2
fr la france president libre et
beaujolais
ah bah there's drapchi everything goes away
it's dying a little
a little
minute vip  in zurich station
stephen ferris costs
here are those of the anagrams to this minister
he smokes federal carved woerth it is a
big source commission of the president
carries large sums 8:06 p.m. crystal
in a row in bahia foam big area
abou oud
because touching kill me he does not
leaves me stadt he spoke to me the same
correct level wished to leave they smoke
gotailloux fallas fear that everything
leaves life on Thursday
and fraud is your right to the taste of
knowledge president of the sivos holt
in fact despite everything sharing
scouts Arab governments remain
excluded that become pro christophe his
surroundings he all made must
tendriade of the ertt I said that leaving
is dying a little
and I can take advantage of the opportunity
offered to me to thank you the
general secretaries that I  I had the
two chiefs of staff who served me
with vehicles, the members of my
cabinet and their assistants, but bodega,
as we say in Frenglish, my drivers
all because here everyone for
the other there is  there is no hierarchy
marcel in a house like ours
I think I can say that you are
lucky to have hatred for
lavender as president of the commission
she will do everything she can do
and she knows how to do a lot of  things
to serve Europe
you have been incredibly loyal to me
sometimes difficult to
beat implement us without you I
could not have done anything and his me you
would have been less efficient
I wanted to say love to you all  I have
the greatest appreciation to see
the operation that the European civil service
which very often is covered
with tiff is often and criticized its
major reasons but the
European civil service and of an exemplary quality
I like said blaise pascal the
French philosopher  the things that go
together and europe and its public service
these are things that go together from
france to help new delhi come all
fake iron diskan gave
directives of black desire of the public
towards this cause there
will bring  since a people to gaza including
4.5
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
not glop
for that
[Applause]
I'll give you the president's bell
I was given  this bell at the
beginning of my mandate
the initial idea was to ring the
bell
when an intervention took more than
3 minutes
all interventions
always took more than three minutes each
a class that is absolutely useless
[Applause]
mario jean claude  of stairs and radio
one way you are one of the founder of
sound nature 6th and beat speak french to
the president a german earlier said as it
had done at new world tour but
empty policy
human rights
this policy creates desire in north
shore gold  brook and their manager all
protect your app inventor is no it
beats me once read columbo european
american and we may be very very thing
for date 10 february nothing is in fact
that you have obsolete and rebirth
as per this beautiful jersey longe on
investment and  many todd edwards navas
accident again from lyon car strolls but
crosby comes out of the fairy fingers
bagnolet demonstrate fun family and
maurice bidouilh open hack solid
history effect film he is optimistic
and costumes of the union delegations
we decide
when it rains jean claude berri  picchu
fils not only when it comes to you tube
you asked us to take care of
europe and nobody took care of
europe as much as you i promise you
we will do our best but
i also hope that  you don't want to
deprive us of your advice you
advanced it and your intelligence doesn't
need you yet you
just quoted a favorite quote the
roof of blaise pascal
i like the things that go together
today i think  i can say on behalf
of all of us here
jean claude juncker and europe will
always go together book jean claude and
jean michenot to a big attack have
we be able to say fly9 d'asbestos
the overall estimate at the polls
in  ten dead or injured
einstein
lexmark genesis canap [ __ ] of
stematch jokes in the town film in the film
by henri stouff crosby at the ascott group at
mercy
[Applause] [
Music] [Music
]
[Music]
rens